bonjour nous sommes le vendredi 4
septembre nouvelle édition du journal de
la rédaction de télé fils journal
d'information locale voici les
principaux titres hall la fsu des
yvelines syndicat enseignant a aussi
fait sa rentrée c'était hier à
mantes-la-jolie au cours d'une
conférence de presse pour pointer les
difficultés rencontrées et les
changements et qui sont attendus les 6
et 13 décembre prochains les électeurs
votent pour renouveler les conseillers
régionaux en ile de france claude
bartolone entend conserver la région à
gauche mais la lutte sera difficile face
notamment à valérie pécresse pour les
républicains
nous en parlerons sur ce plateau avec
benoît hamon député numéro 2 pour cette
élection dans les yvelines et puis comme
chaque vendredi l'essentiel de la
semaine rentrée des classes son corps
mobilisation des agriculteurs au coeur
de l'actualité
l'invité de ce vendredi c'est donc
benoît hamon bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau député ps des yvelines
conseiller municipal de trappes et
candidat aux régionales en île de france
on va parler de votre actualité de
l'actualité yvelinoise également au
cours de la prochaine demi heure tout
d'abord une question hier dans les
colonnes de l'humanité vous avez annoncé
la création d'un mouvement pour cet
automne est ce que vous confirmez
est ce que ce mouvement 20 s'inscrire
aussi dans la mouvance du parti
socialiste c'est un peu différent c'est
pas un parti politique c'est vraiment
moi c'est vous tous mécènes j'en suis
pas à l'origine des erreurs des
notamment un parlementaire pouria
amirshahi qui avait travaillé à cette
idée là qui était de faire en sorte
aujourd'hui que ceux qui s'engagent sur
le terrain dans
des formes de solidarité comme dans
l'entrepreneuriat social dans les sites
d'économie collaborative de crowdfunding
dans l'innovation pédagogique dans les
monnaies locales qui se met déjà les
solidarités quand il se politise dit-il
se politise sans les socialistes
voulaient même très souvent contre les
socialistes et c'est intéressant de voir
que personne ne propose que toutes ces
initiatives d'une manière ou d'une autre
convergent pour essayer prendra du temps
hautmont contesta blement de dessiner un
horizon en termes d'intérêt général et
de solidarité c'est l'objectif de ce
mouvement soit bien clair ce mouvement
sera à l'intérieur du parti soigner
mignon ses amarres d'ailleurs ces
derniers qui complètement différent qui
m'aiment beaucoup plus horizontale qui
sera très très innovant dans ses formes
d'organisation qui ne se réclamera
d'aucun parti donc tu es mal mais mais
j'ai trouvé beaucoup d'intérêt pour la
création de ce mouvement parce que je
pense qu'on a besoin de se régénérer nos
repères nos codes dont on voit
aujourd'hui pour les français le clivage
droite gauche puis dire grand chose mais
ça c'est pas incompatible avec une
candidature pour les régionales sous
l'étiquette du parti socialiste parce
qu'on imagine ce mouvement fait aussi
d'une certaine manière
suite à vos prises de position non à la
gauche de la gauche pour pour simplifier
mais l'objectif c'est pas c'est pas mon
parti a su mais je sais pas s'il y aura
des adhésions l'objectif c'est que ça
c'est un groupe de réflexion alors non
on recherche aujourd'hui des formes
inspirées de ce qui se passe dans
beaucoup de pays occidentaux
libero tôt aux états unis en angleterre
en espagne en grèce et en amérique
latine de formes d'organisation qui
permettent les échanges qu'on trouve
plus aujourd'hui en démocratie ou quand
apolitique organisé une réunion et il
est là pour faire la leçon rarement
écouter et jamais mis sur le même pied
d'égalité que son auditoire bon moi j'ai
j'aspire à des formes aujourd'hui aéré
plus oxygéné démocratie et ce vol un peu
peut être une de ses formes demain on en
revient à ses différentes déclarations
de ces derniers jours vous avez aussi
évoqué l'idée d'une candidature à la
primaire de 2017 à gauche vous y pensez
souvent nord il ya quand même une
premier conditionnelle qui est qui
vivent près mais main gauche ce qui
n'est pas sûr pour l'instant moi je
milite depuis longtemps pour que cette
innovation démocratique que dont nous
sommes à l'origine qui est reprise
aujourd'hui par les républicains qui va
faire donner lieu j'espère une belle
confrontation démocratique pas une
bataille de chiffonniers
je crois qu'il ya quelques personnalités
qui sont parfaitement capables de
devenir un débat intéressant du côté des
républicains je pense qu'à gauche
cette innovation démocratique et elle
doit continuer à vivre dans l'hypothèse
où il y aurait des primaires de gauche
s'est dit que je n'excluais pas ce choix
ce qui ne veut pas dire que j'ai décidé
d'y aller mais que je considère
aujourd'hui pour l'entendre entre deux
mois qu'il ya une parole aujourd'hui
parole de gauche qui me continue à
croire à l'importance de la lutte contre
les inégalités la pauvreté aussi qu'on
constate je vous avais dit s'il ya une
primaire ça veut dire qu'il ya quand
même une forte probabilité pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de primaire je pense que
c'est
une hypothèse qui n'y en ait pas des
doigts ces cas là les choses seront
différentes mais ma préférence va je
vous le dis est ce qu'on répète
l'exercice des primaires messi a pas de
lumière
si françois hollande se représente à
nouveau candidat soutenait le candidat
de la gauche naturellement j'ai ça soit
candidat ou si de fait il est le
candidat de la gauche il sera mon
candidat
éducation à présent puisque nous allons
passer à l'actualité du jour dans les
yvelines avant de revenir tout à l'heure
sur les régionales avec vous et cette
rentrée du syndicat enseignant fsu
conférence de presse depuis et mantes la
jolie et jeudi soir donc qui hier à la
fsu des yvelines qui est mobilisée
notamment contre la réforme des collèges
des explications de fanny bourdillon et
de william l c'est à mantes-la-ville que
la fédération de syndicats fsu a
inauguré sa nouvelle permanence de
septembre quatre syndicats et une
vingtaine d'éducateurs se sont
rassemblés pour une rencontre avec la
presse dans leur viseur en cette rentrée
la réforme des collèges et et rythmes
scolaires sur trappe
nous vivons notre troisième année de
deux nouveau rythme scolaire et force
est de constater que le résultat n'est
vraiment pas à la hauteur des ambitions
qui avaient été affichés au départ
puisque les parents d'élèves et les
élèves perdre les études surveillées et
que les les nappes qui devait être une
ouverture sur le monde se réduisent de
plus en plus à de simples garderies à
peine améliorée les syndicats fustigent
des réformes qui ne serait pas adapté au
terrain l'autonomie des établissements
la transdisciplinarité mais aussi
l'accompagnement personnalisé en
l'accompagnement personnalisé je pense
que c'est la grande fumisterie du siècle
puisque les parents d'élèves au moment
du la réforme du lycée on leur a vendu
la réforme en leur expliquant qu'on a
les apports compagne et individuellement
chacun de leurs enfants on leur a dit
qu'on leur donnerait deux heures à
chaque élève
comment des dotations ces deux heures
par classe suffit de faire les calculs
35 élèves par classe deux heures par
classe c'est pas 2 heures par élève si
on voulait vraiment faire les choses
correctement c'est pas 2 mai 8h par
classe qu'il faudrait au cours de cette
conférence de presse les syndicats
enseignants ont aussi abordé les
questions qui font l'actualité de cette
rentrée les migrants le chômage et
l'europe
benoît hamon vous avez été ministre de
l'éducation et surtout aujourd'hui vous
êtes conseiller municipal à trappes
qu'ils aient mis directement en cause à
travers la parole de la fsu autour des
temps d'activités périscolaires vous
souhaitiez réagir oui je suis très déçu
parce que surtout de la part d'un
instituteur c'est pas correct de dire
des choses qui ne sont pas exacts la
première d'entre elles c'est de rappeler
qu'il revient et c'est la responsabilité
de l'éducation nationale et pas des
mairies que doit organiser l'aide aux
devoirs et l'étude est notamment l'étude
surveillée et qu'en l'occurrence des
engagements étaient pris pour que
l'éducation nationale sur la base du
volontariat des professeurs avec un
paiement de ses heures supplémentaires
qui sera effectué c'est cette ses
devoirs soient soit réalisé cette aide
individuelle aux devoirs soit faite
s'est inscrit et ce sera préparée pour
l'année prochaine de surcroît jeu moi
j'aimerais que cet instituteur rappelle
que attrape comme ailleurs on a constaté
quoi que grâce aux nouveaux rythmes
éducatif qui sont organisés et vous
rappelle que le but c'était pas
d'organiser des activités périscolaires
ça ça vient après mais c'était de faire
en sorte qu'on puisse avoir une matinée
de plus pour apprendre le français les
mathématiques
on est en avance dans la plupart des
écoles sur les programmes
c'est à dire qu'on a eu du temps
supplémentaire pour revoir ça va marcher
mais sur l'organisation de huit ans
après les courses à gré plus compliqué
at rappelait beaucoup d'oppositions de
la station qui savait bien de parents
d'élèves qu'attendez-vous de l'école
sinon qu' à la fin du primaire en cm2
votre enfant sage parler écrire
correctement et lire correctement le
français et sachent connaît le
maîtrisent les apprentissages
fondamentaux mathématiques c'est ce que
vous attendez pour qu'ensuite au collège
ils sont en capacité de réussir son
collège puis son lycée
aujourd'hui l'école rencontrent des
difficultés dans les apprentissages
fondamentaux d'où la réforme des rythmes
éducatif d'où les nouveaux programmes et
c'est ce qui donnera des résultats et je
demande aux parents de com - même si
parents d'élèves et je le vois sur mais
sur mes propres enfants voient pas les
effets d'une année sur l'autre mais
incontestablement dès les deux premières
années on a constaté quoi que les
professeurs étaient en avance sur les
programmes ce qui leur a permis de 2
mieux travailler ou de mieux peaufiner
les apprentissages fondamentaux dont moi
je crois que sur le plan de la classe c
mieux après incontestablement
l'organisation des activités
périscolaires
elle suppose de l'ajustement trappe
c'est 200 intervenants
mais ces intervenants mais vous imaginez
ce que c'est 200 intervenants qui pour
les uns interviennent que deux heures là
puis ensuite deux heures ailleurs donc
c'est une organisation considérable qui
suppose donc de s'ajuster et c'est ce
que font toutes les communes pour celles
qui en organise par exemple elancourt
vous n'avez pas de contenu vous avez
attrape vous pouvez d'avoir toute une
série d'activités
alors je comprends que les instituteurs
qui ne sont plus là au moment où il ya
les activités périscolaires considère
qu'elles sont pas bonnes bon cet
instituteur la représentant d'un
syndicat ou même la jeunesse marc
antoine respecter les syndicats moi j'ai
dû tout je les ai toujours associé au
choix politique que je faisais quo
prévaut réforme des rythmes scolaires et
je me souviens que s'il y avait des
réserves du côté du syndicat fsu et
notamment de son syndicat dans le
premier degré y avait aussi la
reconnaissance que pour l'essentiel sur
le contenu qui se passe en classe
il ya du mieux à réformer l'équipe
éducative est donc très brièvement sur
les revenus de la variété dans les
syndicats aussi et des tendances il ya
des tendances et ça vous le savez bien
du parti socialiste que j'ai c'est
l'expert qui vous sur les sur les
réformes justement est très brièvement
pour qu'on ait quand même du temps pour
parler des régionales juste après sur la
réforme réforme des collèges qui a été
lancé imaginez ensuite par celle qui
vous a succédé au ministère de
l'éducation c'est najat vallaud belkacem
vous en pensez quoi c'est une bonne ou
mauvaise chose cette réforme des
collèges qui déclenche pas mal de
contestation elle reste bien trop
d'applications septembre 2016
elle se mettra en application à ce tour
2016 elle prévoit quoi d'abord que les
établissements et plus d'autonomie
pédagogique avec 20 % du temps qui
pourrait être pensé en fonction de ce
que sont les besoins d'un collège au
regard des besoins des élèves du
territoire ça va donc donner une forme
de respiration pédagogique qui
n'existait pas auparavant
ensuite on a fait en sorte que pour ce
qui est de l'apprentissage de la
deuxième longue pour ce qui est
l'apprentissage
du latin du grec on ne réserve pas ces
options finalement à ceux qui sont issus
des familles qui ont les codes de la
réussite c'est à dire qu'ils savent
quelles options il faut prendre pour est
ensuite dans le bon établissement qui
ensuite préparera aux bons lycées etc
donc c'est qu'elles sont les familles
qui ont les codes de la réussite
scolaire mais permettent donc à tous les
enfants de pouvoir disposer d une
deuxième langue et de l'apprendre plus
tôt qu'auparavant
et puis de t'avoir outre des
connaissances sur les fondations des
grandes civilisations antiques mais
également un apprentissage du grec et du
latin donc c'est une bonne réforme
oui je pense que c'est une réforme qui a
pas d' ajustements à faire mais c'est
toujours des discussions avoir moi je ne
pense que quand les syndicats vous dit
ça ne va pas il faut toujours les
écouter par définition considérer que
les syndicats ont tort puis mes jambes
j'ai autant désormais que que qu'à
droite on considère que les syndicats de
l'éducation nationale ont raison c'est
nouveau mais moi je me dis moi je leur
donne pas tort parce qu'ils protestent
parce que je crois qu'il ya des
remarques qu'il faut entendre
après tout les professeurs ce sont eux
qui sont dans les salles de classe ce
sont eux qui sont font face chaque année
à des classes de 25 30 voire même plus
de 30 élèves et en collège et je vous
prie de croire que c'est difficile
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles je
pense qu'il faut les soutenir c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles aussi moi
j'ai proposé que pour ce qui concerne
les et les instituteurs du primaire
double et professeurs des écoles aux
primaires la prime de 400 euros par an
qu'ils ont pour accompagner
individuellement les élèves puisque on
leur demande beaucoup ces instituteurs
et bien elles soient portés à 1200 euros
par an c'est à dire le montant de la
prime que perçoivent leurs collègues du
second degré ce que la prime pour la
même tâche est de 1200 euros
dans le second degré et elle n'est que 2
400 euros dans le premier degré voilà
une mesure qui pourrait utilement
soutenir les professeurs du premier
degré au moment où on leur demande
beaucoup j'espère que le gouvernement
reprendra sa propre cette proposition le
prochain budget en tout cas on était
sûrement pour la défendre les régionales
à présent avant que vous écoutez sur
cette campagne petit rappel pratique
vous pouvez encore vous inscrire sur les
listes électorales le reportage à suivre
est signée william l il reste trois mois
avant le premier tour de l'élection
régionale mais il n'en reste qu'un pour
s'inscrire sur les listes électorales
cette année grâce à
adoption d'une loi par le parlement les
citoyens ont jusqu'au 30 septembre pour
s'inscrire en mairie
alors il faut apporter une pièce
d'identité carte d'identité ou passeport
en cours de validité et un justificatif
de domicile à votre non daté de moins de
trois mois
autre solution plus simple et plus
rapide l'inscription par internet le
ministère de l'intérieur propose une
plateforme spéciale permettant
l'inscription en ligne
pour cela il suffit de se connecter sur
le site mon service-public puis cliquer
sur l'onglet téléservices et complétez
le formulaire
ça arrive directement chez nous et on
reçoit sa carte électorale comme
n'importe pour n'importe quelques
inscriptions donc pour cette année ce
sera début décembre le jour du vote il
n'est pas nécessaire de présenter sa
carte électorale une pièce d'identité
suffit c'est un droit c'est un devoir et
on peut pas laisser la responsabilité
aux autres de
des décisions politiques il faut
s'investir au moins en allant voter sur
la commune de montigny 24 milles 576
électeurs sont déjà inscrits sur les
listes pour la verrière ce sont plus de
3000 personnes un chiffre qui reste
stable comparé aux élections
départementales
benoît hamon candidat ps derrière claude
bartolone qui est aujourd'hui le
président de l'assemblée nationale où
êtes numéro deux dans les yvelines
pourquoi cette candidature aux
régionales alors que j'ai tout de même
rappeler vous avez démissionné de ce
conseil régional vous avez été élu lors
de la précédente mandature c'est en 2010
octobre 2014
vous respectez la loi de cumul des
mandats puisque vous êtes député vous
avez aussi été ministre d'ailleurs et là
vous revenez pour la région s'il ya un
gros enjeu ce que la région ne bascule
pas du côté de même pécresse ou regarder
les propositions qu'elle faisait sur le
lycée par exemple on va y venir sur le
lycée mais je france là et je pourrais
prendre quelques autres exemples je
crois qu'il y aurait un grand danger à
ce que tous les efforts qui ont été
mobilisés pour essayer de restaurer et
s'il ya encore énormément de travail
qualité de transport rénover les
infrastructures avoir une île de france
qui soit pas juste une collectivité très
éloignés des habitants mais se
préoccupent concrètement d'aspect très
concret de leur vie quotidienne en
matière de formation professionnelle en
matière d'éducation en matière de
soutien à la création d'entreprise
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce sont de
vieilles idées portées par madame
pécresse notamment sur l'organisation du
lycée le fait de donner
de l'autonomie au lycée dans des
proportions qui amènerait naturellement
les élèves qui ne choisissent pas leur
lycée à se retrouver dans une grande
inégalité d'un territoire un autre je
pense que voilà c'était pour moi c'est
un combat important
l'objectif qu'a fixé claude bartolone
autour de ce slogan en ile-de-france
humaine me semble être un objectif à la
fois simple et extrêmement ambitieux
quand il faut faire et pour ne prendre
qu'un exemple et des domaines dans
lesquels il n'y a pas de compétences
obligatoires
je pense à la prise en charge de la
petite enfance je pense aux réponses que
nous devons faire comme collectivité
publique aux mères célibataires
une famille sur quatre en ile de france
c'est une famille monoparentale et 85%
d'entre elles ce sont des femmes seules
avec des enfants qui ont un travail mais
qui souvent avec des horaires décalés
pas de solution je pense qu'il faudra
apporter des réponses et trouver mais
j'espère que tout cas je suis certain
que la campagne que nous allons faire on
apportera je suis l exercice difficile
qui consiste à préparer le projet parce
que vous êtes en charge du projet projet
parmi elles ne pas pouvoir vous donner
toutes les propositions s'offre elle est
allée rendre public avant que le
candidat claude bartolone l'effet des
projets il est terminée nous il
travaille au corps il ya d'abord il ya
un exercice citoyen participatif on a
sollicité beaucoup de réseaux de tête de
réseau d'acteurs de la vie associative
culturelle économique et
entrepreneuriale pour qu'il remonte des
demandes et on est pour l'instant cet
exercice là même si il sera finalisé
quand je pense que
mi octobre vous aurez les grandes lignes
du projet de claude bartolone qui
s'appuiera à la fois sur le bilan le
pass navigo est aujourd'hui réparé ni
pollution effectivement on n'a pas
précisé avec jean mais ça sent le grand
hangar réalisa mais qui permet
maintenant à chacun de pouvoir circuler
beaucoup plus facilement et à des tarifs
qui n'ont qui est donc plus grand chose
à voir avec ce qui se passait dans le
passé on a eu un engagement extrêmement
fort combattue par madame pécresse et
que nous avons mis en oeuvre j'espère
qu'elle le gardera en dépit du fait
qu'elle l'ait combattu si jamais elle
devait être un jour présidente de la
région en tout cas qu'elles s'engagent
là dessus mais on pourrait devoir pour
éviter les mauvaises surprises
il faut à mon avis mais ce que je
voudrais je me battrai pour ça non
seulement poursuivre en matière de
politique de transport ce que vous avez
commencé mais se donner une nouvelle
énergie avec l'autre bord mais faire ce
projet puisque vous êtes en charge du
projet c'est un exercice difficile parce
que on imagine qu'à votre sensibilité
dedans on vraiment de gauche de la
gauche de la gauche il faut pas france
et manuel valls il faut pas froisser
françois hollande
emmanuel macron aussi vous arrivez à
tout conjugué à temps d'éventuels alliés
ou si les campagnes par exemple il ya eu
un point de discorde tout de même déjà
c'est la création d'une écotaxe par
exemple elle est souhaité par claude
bartolone en ile de france où les poids
lourds aux tours l'étoile où les poids
lourds qui passent pas chez nous qui
nous donc
mais manuel valls ne veut pas oui bah
écoute et manuel valls il a une position
la région elle n'est pas là pour être
bénis oui oui du gouvernement nous on
considère par exemple et d'autre part
cela dit la coop 21 qui va être
organisée en ile de france
attention à ce que cette organisation ne
provoque pas d'immenses embouteillages
et que la force de mauvais pour la
popularité ce sera mauvais pour se faire
élire oui et puis les voitures qui
tournent au ralenti c'est beau c'est
beaucoup plus polluant desurmont bas
donc il serait quand même et c'est
véritablement ça le problème
oui mais c'est une manière aussi de dire
et de pointer un certain nombre de
difficultés écouter et franciliens pour
certains d'entre eux tout ça va bien
pour d'autres ça pourrait aller mieux si
on est soulagé de tous ces petits
poisons qui empoisonnent leur vie par
définition et il y en a beaucoup et
c'est la tâche d'une région que de le
faire et on fera des propositions vous
le verrez extrêmement concrètes et qui
partiront n'ont pas
duo en essayant d'imaginer à 30 ans ou à
40 ans ce que ce sera l'île de france on
y pensera la transition écologique
énergétique fera partie de nos
préoccupations à soi-même centrale dans
toutes nos orientations mais nous
partirons de ce qu'est la vie de
nombreux franciliens qui pourrait vivre
bien vraiment bien si on levait tous ces
poisons qui aujourd'hui dans leur vie
les affecte les entraves et font
obstacle à une vie simple et aux vous ne
pouvez pas dévoiler le programme on l'a
bien compris il y est encore en cours
d'élaboration on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir mais justement plaisir je
reviendrai pour ré précis mais on
imagine que tous les candidats seront
ravis de venir sur ce plateau ont juste
un point très précis cessé sur les
lycées parce que c'est une compétence
obligatoire de la région sur la gestion
des lycées vous avez évoqué valérie
pécresse justement elle a dévoilé
quelques propositions et puis elle a
aussi organisé une petite campagne
médiatique de pose de fausses premières
pierres devant certains lycées avec les
différents représentants du parti
les républicains pour dénoncer des
travaux qui n'ont jamais été engagée
malgré ce qui avait été dit par la
région c'est le cas du lycée 17 mar par
exemple sur noir pas est en cours on en
voit les images avec les maires des
communes d'elancourt et de maurepas qui
qui ont participé à cette pose de
première pierre et de fausses première
pierre des travaux qui n'ont pas été
menées par la région sauf si ça fait
partie du bilan
mais si on en est vouloir y compris l
encours est mort pas c'est pas le seul
établissement mais un objet fabriqué des
lycées qui aurait conduit à la
destruction d'un autre lycée qui était
défendu mes rations des travaux de
rénovation sur cet établissement qui
n'ont pas été faites votre magasin voire
parle moi j'étais le visiter et je sais
dans quel état il est j'ai été voir les
conditions d'études et j'ai rencontré le
proviseur était et son équipe donc je
connais bien la situation
mais je dois rappeler que l'une des
conséquences
de la construction d'un nouveau lycée ça
aurait été la remise en cause de celui
de la plaine de nos flat rappelé qu'ils
étaient intéressés des lycées qui dans
toute la france a les meilleurs
résultats aujourd'hui au bac
au regard des difficultés qui sont
rencontrés dans pouvez tout de même
rénové selon des seuils sont visés mais
des moyens ont été débloqués pour
rénover pour partir le lycée 17 morts
donc ce que ce que dit madame eux me
pécresse est imparfait est une parfaite
imposture comme sur beaucoup d'autres
lycées est ce que je veux simplement
dire c'est que nous l'éducation
on s'y est concentré d'abord est pas pas
participé ou appartenait au gouvernement
qui a supprimé 80 mille postes de
professeurs moi j'en ai même créé
quelques dizaines de milliers lazare
établi non mais l'avant parler du
gouvernement là moi je pars dans la
région et les financements de la région
et les finances mais bien sûr sur les
investissements jamais autant
d'investissements pour les lycéennes ont
été consentis ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui pour aider à la transition
vers le numérique pour fibrer tous les
établissements tout ça fait partie
aujourd'hui du bilan de la région et
nous irons encore plus loin notamment
sur ce qui est cette petite révolution
qui amènera les salles de classe a
évolué considérablement avec l'irruption
du numérique en équipements mais surtout
en ressources pédagogiques
parce que c'est un moyen aujourd'hui
très utile pour lutter contre les
inégalités notamment des les niveaux
différentes qu'on peut rencontrer dans
certaines classes donc nous avons seront
là dessus ce que je regrette je me
demande à chaque fois pour crazy
brièvement parce qu'on m'a sauvée par
les gens a raconté des histoires lors
des campagnes électorales
elle pourrait parfaitement défendre son
projet où je ne considère pas y respecte
abl parce qu'elle est par répartition
aux républiques et il est respectable et
elle a son opinion son avis mais c'est
pas pour préfériez moi ça fait même pas
fruit d'un nom 4s mais m'a même avant
elle siège doit fonder que politique sur
un mensonge
moi je pense je dis pourquoi fondé à
discours politique et une campagne
électorale sur un mensonge d'une si nous
parce qu'on va continuer à mentir
derrière une dernière question juste
pour finir sur les régionales je vais
rappeler tout à l'heure vous aviez
démissionner lorsque vous avez été lieu
députés pour le cumul des mandats si
vous êtes élu vous faites quoi
un échange je serai je vais
au moment de la région je fais pas polar
est donc aujourd'hui je vais m'appliquer
sur la semblait que je crois aujourd'hui
que c'est important
je vais je prendrai ma décision que je
prendrai ma décision au moment de mon
élection sur le monde a job en oeuvre on
arrête pour les régionales on va revenir
brièvement sur quelques-uns des sujets
de l'actualité de la semaine à présent
un sujet d'actualité locale à présent
qui vous concernent aussi puisque
dorénavant pour accéder à l'île des
loisirs à saint quentin en yvelines il
faudra payer pour tout le monde trois
entrées gratuites seulement pour les
saint quentinois auparavant c'était
gratuit depuis le 1er septembre les
règles ont changé un petit rappel des
faits le parking gratuit c'est fini
depuis le 1er septembre l'accès en
voiture à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines et payant jusqu'à
présent gratuit pour les saint
quentinois ils devront maintenant
s'acquitter de 80 pour franchir les
barrières de l'espace face à des
contraintes budgétaires importantes
la volonté malgré tout de maintenir une
offre de qualité et une extension de
périmètre en prévision aussi donc la
communauté d'agglomération se retrouve
contrainte de revoir effectivement ces
conditions de compensation une
tarification adaptée pour les saint
quentinois tout de même été mise en
place un pass facturé 20 euros
permettant d'y entrer dans l'espace
malgré tout certains habitants restent
mécontents c'est le cas de joël trubuilt
élan courtois qui a mis en ligne une
pétition pour abroger cette mesure
lorsque cette base de loisirs a été mise
en place par la ville de saint quentin
avec des impôts de la lutte de
saint-quentin bon avec des aides
régionales et ont retrouvé l'a62 des
financements c'était saint quentin en
yvelines
donc naturellement un poumon sur la
ville connaissait de base qui est l'une
des plus belles bases de l'île de france
ça paraissait normal qu'elle continue à
rester ouvertes à tous pour le moment
joël a récolté un peu plus de 400
signatures et compte attendre la fin du
mois pour la présenter à la direction
qu'ils de loisirs quant à elle entend
renforcer ses activités sa qualité de
service tout
en garantissant un accès privilégié aux
saint quentinois tarifs préférentiels
pour la base de loisirs l'île des
loisirs plus de gratuité automatique
mais bon je regrette donc ici et j'ai
aussi au conseil d'agglomération
légèrement dans les décisions
c'est une décision qui une fois de plus
de la communauté d'agglomération qui
fait payer les saint quentinois jeux
vidéo vont payer sous la forme
aujourd'hui une baisse des subventions
toutes les compagnies équipements
culturels à l'exception d'une prise mais
d'utiliser loisirs il ya il faut de
l'argent sa base de loisirs 1 coûte cher
c'est de valeur rapporte pas beaucoup
mieux et il ya de nouveaux saint
quentinois qui vont arriver aussi à
partir du 1er janvier prochain nous dès
qu'on met si on l'avait argile à
l'investissement il ya quand même une
base d'investissements publics et qui je
pense que cette gratuité elle était
légitime d'abord parce que tout le monde
y va on est comme on y va régulièrement
et que là je pense que c'est
je ne vois pas la priorité qu'il y avait
à à mettre 7 finalement à faire payer
les saint quentinois je pense que c'est
une mauvaise mesure
si je devais rapprocher ça aussi deux
cent mille euros en moins pour la
mission locale
rendez compte très con aujourd'hui on
peut se permettre de sacrés des jeux de
jouer avec les soubresauts natalia
peut-être accord avec les choix qui ont
été prénommée manon sienne au pass pour
l'emploi ce sont juste les jeunes qui
cherchent de l'emploi de son mi novembre
voilà vous pouvez dire monsieur fourgous
200000 euros en moins pour la mission
locale pour l'emploi
ben là s'illustre une politique est une
politique qui va aggraver le chômage
un autre sujet d'actualité ce sont les
agriculteurs qui ont manifesté cette
semaine c'était jeudi est également
fière on va en voir quelques images les
agriculteurs et qui conteste les normes
qui sont mis en place trop stricte et
qui souhaitent également de nouveaux
crédits une réflexion sur
l'assouplissement des normes pour ces
professions je le disais et ça a été en
partie or obtenues par les annonces qui
ont été faites par le gouvernement
le gouvernement a bien réagi c'est
légitime honnêtement les éleveurs de
porcs aujourd'hui est en situation de
pouvoir vivre de ce qu'ils font et je
sais que c'est un travail durant bible à
raison des prix qui sont pratiqués sur
les marchés des prix qui sont imposés
par la grande distribution aux
transformateurs et ensuite par les
transformateurs aux éleveurs je pense
qu'il fallait les aider c'est légitime
c'est un mouvement qui pour l'essentiel
elle a été non violent et je m'en
réjouis que ce qui était proposé va dans
le bon sens ce qui est proposé va dans
le bon sens
merci benoît hamon candidat donc aux
régionales numéro deux dans les yvelines
carrière sandrine gros gants dernière
sur le grand drame qui n'est pas avec
nous puisque pour des raisons d'agenda
ne pouvais pas te présente aujourd'hui
quelques informations vous donner avant
de refermer ce journal les forums des
associations qui débute dès ce week-end
plusieurs communes organisent elles ont
cours complexe de l'europe de 9h à 17h à
montigny gymnase coubertin 9h 18h
également et puis à plaisir dès 10
heures au gymnase à cela un appui du
côté de trappes dans votre commune
également ural forum des associations
qui va se tenir reprise également pour
nos confrères de radio sensations
toujours sur la même fréquence 98 points
4 à partir de lundi 6h10 le matin
l'agenda loisirs et le flash locale qui
revient à partir de 17h30 avec nicolas
kirilow vcsa voilà le journal lui
revient à lundi sur tv fil aux mêmes
horaires
vous retrouverez dorénavant pour la
présentation florane parfait je vous
donne rendez vous pour l'édition du
vendredi qui reviendra largement sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
et puis dans les prochains jours je vous
retrouverai aussi pour le les reprises
du 7-8 politique et du café politique
la semaine prochaine ce sera la rentrée
sur tv fil pour vous différents
magazines sport société culture loisirs
avec michael et demi d'euros nouradine
agne sephora à manier et mélanie ok je
vous souhaite d'ici là un excellent week
end
il